all right I got a brand new hour of
stand-up material Tiki wikis at
christycomedy.com we added shows in
Florida West Palm Beach March 28th 29th
we have Vancouver February 22nd I'll be
there for the Just for Laughs Comedy
Festival Phoenix Arizona January 26th to
the 28th and I'll be in Austin to kick
off moon tower Festival all those
tickets on sale chrisdcomedy.com of
course New Year's Eve in Huntington New
York Long Island and then next Thursday
in Charlotte Friday in Asheville
Saturday in Charleston I think tickets
are sold out or closer sold out
chrisdcomedy.com for Ticky Wiki's brand
new hour of stand-up material come
through I'm going to kiss the front row
on the lips
foreign
[Music]
what's up everybody Welcome to hey babe
we are here Sal vulcano's back this is
what Sal looks like this week yep look
at that look at how hot sounds
ugly now
[Laughter]
Sal's an ugly gay guy now I just wanna
I want the record to show that I said
yes to doing this because I thought Sal
was going to be here but yeah we put up
a Twitter poll of course
only Joe santigato the Christmas cat we
up a Twitter poll because Joe was kind
enough to do this uh show for us to fill
in for salvocano who will be back next
week
um and um
and I said he said is that am I doing
yours meaning Chrissy chaos or the one
you do with Sal and I said you know what
I'm gonna just tell him that Sal's gonna
be there so he shows up and then I said
let's just put it on Twitter and what do
the fans think I should do should I lie
or tell the truth and the fans voted to
tell the truth Escape well so when I
told you the truth I said Sal won't be
Sal won't be here yeah but it's nothing
personal but then you said I'll pay you
a bunch of money so that's why I do
ultimately I'll pay you a bunch of money
and when you got we got you a bacon egg
and cheese with salt pepper and ketchup
it's a very New York Puerto Rican order
I was a Puerto Rican I feel like salt
pepper ketchup's more Puerto Rican work
just ketchup is white and just salt
pepper no ketchup is black I mean
I don't know about that also the Taylor
Taylor what is it Taylor Hammond oh
Taylor yeah dude is that like Jersey
trash Jersey trash when you're like oh
can I get a can I get a um uh when they
say egg and cheese on on a what is it a
pork roll do they say what the [ __ ] is
that a Taylor Ham they say Jersey as a
student I don't even know what that is
New Jersey egg sandwiches what is it
what's Taylor Ham I don't know what
Taylor ham is I only know Taylor Swift
and I love her music and I couldn't get
tickets to a show nobody could nobody
can no signal detected look we just got
a new TV in the new studio yeah there's
no signal detected yeah is that what do
you think you think it's gonna work in
here you think my career is on going
down I mean it seems to be working
Against All Odds so seriously right
that's because your brother runs my
digital lamp
whoever see me infiltrate your Facebook
or social media with you know show dates
and plugs for my next venues it's
because of Joe santigato's brother
Thomas who's just he's he's like a
little it's like he works for the CCP in
China he just he just corrupts files and
he just infiltrates yeah that's what he
does and he gets in he's like a Saudi
Arabian [ __ ] one of those Saudi
Arabian software spies and the thing is
he knows a lot of terminology so if you
ask him any questions like what does
this mean and then he says stuff and I'm
like oh all right I have no idea what
the [ __ ] he's talking about but it's
good you need you need someone like that
in this world he's like the guy he's
he's the most important part of the of
your crew is you need the digital people
you need the homeless pimps you need to
tell them Simon sent the goddos yeah she
need the homeless pimps yeah Divinity
yes you need vanity right by the way
speaking of homeless people I just saw
someone give a box of latex gloves to a
homeless person like out of their car
like they were like you know how they
come by your car and they're like yo
please and I just put my [ __ ] head
down I'm like I'm texting
can't even see someone just handed a
whole box of latex gloves that were
opened interesting just a homeless how
do you know why do you are you positive
he was homeless
maybe it's just a guy getting kova
tested on the street it could it could
have been no I'm pretty certain they
were homeless just judging by the
appearance I'm mimicking you
subconsciously you you did your leg now
I do my leg like that
you're a guy that can pull off ankle
socks anyone ever tell you that why you
don't do ankle socks no baby I go high I
go high sometimes yeah but if you're
gonna wear those you got to go high I
wear I protect my ankles like a Hasidic
Jewish one protects her head
I don't let anybody see my ankle
wait are they not allowed each other I
feel like I've seen something you'll
never see a married Hasidic Jewish
Woman's real hair
all day they do wig yeah yeah you will
never see that real here where my studio
is in Brooklyn up there's it's you know
there's a lot of Hasidic Jews there
really and in the building I live there
but I have the the my office spaces in
Brooklyn Navy yard and right around
there like if you're gonna get on the
highway
like going home they're everywhere
everywhere yeah dude Brooklyn Navy yard
is it's one of those places where you
don't think anything's going on there
but there's a whole world in the
Brooklyn Navy there is there's like a
[ __ ] Winery on a rooftop over there
like yeah I would like it there by the
way it's okay you know what it is in the
Navy yards cool but outside of it
there's legit nothing nothing it's a
Barren Wasteland it's like being on
Staten Island yeah exactly like that I
love Staten Island I do love Staten
Island but I'm being honest with you
living there for the past year it makes
me it's such a nice place I can't deal
with the suburbs I want to sell the
house and move to the city I wanna
really I feel like I'm gonna commit
suicide in that house because there's
not enough going on there's nothing
going on I I know that it's first world
problems I get this I know it's not like
we're living in Qatar here I just which
could by the way what is Qatar gonna do
with those stadiums when people leave
what are you gonna do when Cristiano
Ronaldo and everyone leaves you could
now you just have 10 stadiums that
nothing how many people are now going to
die taking down the stadiums
um probably the same amount I would say
what was it like 1500 people that's what
they say if they're because if they're
selling 15 000 you know that it's a lot
fifteen thousand took it took a zero off
probably yeah I the last time the World
Cup uh the United States was in the
World Cup in 2014 you and I hung out in
a bar remember that
yes I do it wow that's [ __ ] crazy in
Astoria I remember that because and it
was a [ __ ] bar by the way yes
on the bar there was
no there was a little person and he was
he was dressed as Uncle Sam and he was
pouring shots in everyone's mouths yeah
and that was kind of like my first real
interaction with a little person I'm not
gonna lie yeah like up close at least
yeah that was my first encounter
sexually with a little person yeah magic
we just think it was a little person but
it was actually Dr fauci but just before
he was famous
technically how old how tall is he found
she's a little guy he's a little dude
there is a cut off it's like 410
um you know what I thought about the
other day tell me you never see a guy
right you know
women who are like
4 10 and like five foot five one
whatever I don't know any five foot one
dudes like they're either like a little
person or they're like five five but no
one's like a dude five two a grown dude
a grown man who doesn't have a condition
you don't see any five one guys very
interesting yeah I'm trying to think if
I just because that sucks that sucks to
be the height like especially being a
guy to be like where somebody looks at
you and says does that guy have a
condition or does he not where you're on
the cusp and you don't because for that
if I was 5-1 as a guy I'd rather than
just be four or five I'd rather have the
condition probably either give me the
condition and knock me down a few inches
or let me be six six yeah you know what
I mean like I don't I can't be five one
it's a gray area you can't you're
playing for both teams you're not
playing for any team you're just in this
weird Uranus yeah you're in that you're
in that nether region man well I heard
nowadays like if uh a little person is
pregnant they can predict it and change
that the baby's not you can choose if
the baby stays little see that's messed
up wait what so is he basically saying
if two little people are or or even a
non-little person having a bit pregnant
with a baby and they know the baby's
gonna be a little person which I don't
know how because all babies are little
so I don't know how you can predict that
this one's gonna stay little but but
somehow they're able to predict that
this this person is not going to grow
from a baby to a big person it's going
to just always stay little they can
reverse it in utero and actually make
that would have been little baby into a
big into a bigger person okay but this
is divided the little person community
yeah how dare you choose not to have a
little person yeah that's kind of like a
like a like a like a sort of like a
trans situation because you're like a
proud be proud if you're going to be
little then be proud to be little don't
change that because it's kind of weird
because I guess the little people are
saying is it a condition like you know
just so what I'm little I still can do
everything else everybody else can do
get things off shelves it's not like the
majority like
you know no like you know I don't like
to use the word normal but it's like
most people are a certain way so if they
are not that then they aren't
whatever that word is that I'm not gonna
use normal in LP
you're an LP a little person yeah
uh I yeah I don't know man I I think if
I truthfully was if if I was having a
yet another child and that child was
going to be little I would keep that
little [ __ ] little
this is the first I'm hearing about this
I don't even know if I trust someone to
be in there oh yeah we'll just like fix
it up and we'll like make it figures
brought it up that means it's been
verified on Reddit and it's true well uh
shout out Nick novicky he's a little
person who's also a famous comedian and
he has a documentary about this shout
out Little Nick novicky great kid nick
novicky uh La comic great guy
I imagined he was in The Sopranos legend
legend love love Nick novicky um great
dude now speaking of Nick novicky what
taste buds yes you got into was it hot
water I think this is the real reason
Sal's not here what because what is it
because I don't actually know what is it
uh well there was a couple viral clips
of you guys arguing food oh yeah okay oh
no I and I I saw a bunch of comments
being like this is [ __ ] taste they're
so sure oh my God I can't wait till you
meet DeRosa yeah so do you think DeRosa
has an issue with it like rose has an
issue with all of us yeah deroza hates
us all
um I think yeah but here's the thing
here's the thing so what what food were
you guys arguing because I don't know I
don't know that like that happens
all right but yeah it's hard to not
argue food or just anything like me and
Frank I've known Frank who I do the
podcast with let's have some Pre-K so
like and we rarely agree on [ __ ]
anything Pre-K before kindergarten
oh pretty gay this has been hey babe
have a good one we've known him since
Pre-K yeah I've known it since Pre-K
uh okay yes and uh yeah we've just like
argued about everything he looks like
he's in the pre-kk
um
Frank yeah how does he eat cookies again
isn't it a very he yeah the other day he
said that he eats cookies by like taking
like three or four of them and he like
crumbles them up and puts him in a bowl
and then puts a milk on it you guys made
it on to the Today Show
yeah well they played us awesome they
played a clip on the pot on the they
played a clip from the podcast on The
Today Show did they bring you guys on to
the today no no no that sucks so did
they tell you we're gonna my mom loves
that woman by the way which one Hoda
dude how do you know
Al Roker's been in the hospital for the
last two weeks Al Roka if you're
listening and we know that you are we
hope you get better I shared her uh I
was at the uh a hotel in Puerto Rico
with you at the same time uh we were
there together at the same time and I
came up to you on the elliptical and
made a uh what you deemed as a racist
Whitney Houston joke I swear to God what
did you say I forgot what I said I had
Whitney Houston on my shirt he was on
the elliptical and he snapped he went
that's [ __ ] racist I think something
no it just bombed I think I I had a
picture of Whitney Houston on my shirt
and I think I said something to Al like
oh what's up Al like whatever like
people think this is you or something
stupid I said some joked and I don't
even remember but it bombed and it was
Dumb and Al just looked at me he was
like attacks and then he just like kept
going I think he [ __ ] hated me yeah
but whatever it is Al Roker you seem
like a really nice guy
and but you're in the hospital for the
last three weeks and they have this
other meteorologist woman on see here's
the problem if you people out there want
to get sick and be close to death or you
wanna like sit out of things you gotta
understand there's a lot of hungry mofos
out there that are willing to take your
spot Cristiano Ronaldo sat out of the
World Cup game uh this would be two days
ago and his replacement came in and
scored a hat-trick which is three goals
so now people are like Cristiano who now
they want this new kid you know whoever
this new Portuguese kid is [ __ ] Ramos
whatever who knows what their name
Portugal by the way doesn't get enough
Portugal needs to get in a little bit
more hot water they're the ones that
created slavery just want to put that
out there so why don't we cancel
Portugal I really want to push back on
that but I don't have the you know the I
have nothing to back up my claim on that
Portugal literally are the ones who sold
the original slaves to what would start
the slavery moving in the United States
and Portugal just gets off the hook
while Cristiano Ronaldo I'm not letting
you off the hook talking about getting
off the hook that guy's been in hot
water for quite some time Christian I
don't know what he has also imagine
getting benched in the world cup and
then [ __ ] uh Saudi arabias give them
200 million dollars a year a year dude
that's dude that's Saudi money I I mean
dude it's would you guys live there
could you do it in Saudi Arabia
um depends if the line was finished or
not because I would like to live in that
City the new city the new city that
they're building the line they're
building a new city called the line you
haven't heard about this no no it's a
city that they're building uh and it's
like miles long and it's like vertical
it's like a vertical City if you look up
pictures of it looked desert
it's like mirrored on either side but
they're building this and it's like
billions of dollars and it's going to
say God knows how long I think evil
shits 100 miles yeah yeah very
futuristic yeah and it's in Saudi Arabia
yeah not being built by slaves right
well it's not being built by that's what
yeah
that's what supposedly right well I
don't have any slaves yeah okay but we
don't know but yeah it's like a vertical
City that they're like you know oh look
and they got a soccer stadium football
yeah do you call it football
well no I'm a [ __ ] white person from
Queens we call it soccer for sure are
you really white or why don't you start
telling the truth super white dude
you thought what I no I was saying zoom
in on your face I don't know that you're
I don't know I don't believe that you're
white what do you believe I believe I
believe that you are uh I think you're
an undercover Latino
undercover why would I go undercover
because I think that
um I don't think that you uh support
um Latinos
oh you think there's something like self
yes I think that you are a Latino and it
you're not proud to be and I want to
tell you as a Puerto Rican man you
should be proud I think you get one good
look at my mom and you'd be like this
dude's wife fully white yeah it is
literally Italian Irish I mean dude do
you realize the blessings upon you know
how much Jesus loves you he literally he
literally made you look like a
full-blown Puerto Rican man and said but
you're white
so he gave you the power of a white man
and the looks of a Puerto Rican guy you
literally he gave you the best looks
you're the only person ever that's ever
said that I looked Puerto Rican
does he not look Latino
yes yeah
let's ask the other white people
by the way also looks Latina and she's
Greek yeah but you're you look Italian
as well no no attack I'm not saying a
town I'm saying he looks fully Latino oh
I'm saying that he has a mix like he
literally looks like if I if you said to
me if you said to me the Mets just
signed the Venezuelan relief pitcher and
showed me that picture like this guy
looks [ __ ] great I'm like this guy
looks lights out yeah
like I'll I gotta be honest with you the
first time I met you when you didn't
have not even a hint of a Latino accent
I was shocked I was like this guy's not
saying the Junkies
this guy's just saying the Yankees I was
like you mean the chunkies you were like
no no the Yankees I like the Yankees
which time are you referring to because
we did meet on the set of that show oh
guy Court yeah how great was that that
was and that you know what's funny
because we did that show and then I this
is when I had a complete buzz cut head
like just like pre-kk there you go
um and then the next time I saw you it
was earlier when you were talking about
at that bar yeah
this dude to remember me same calendar
year right was it or pretty no I think
it was I have no idea I thought it was
like I thought it was a while after and
that's why I just like went up to and I
was like hey
and then because we had like spoke like
briefly on like Twitter or something
right and then I was like I don't know
this dude's gonna know who I am but I
was like this dude's in the [ __ ] the
kid Frankie no no no that's my friend
Josh
do you think I look better now or then
dude so now look at you yeah I looks bad
I look bad there right what's wrong with
me there I don't know you look like a
lit like a Komodo dragon it looks dumb
right two baggy of a suit look at that
look at my God look at the star power
schultzy Charlemagne
very lanky there yes schultzy looks the
same though I feel like Chelsea still
looks the same exactly no there's some
old pictures that are really bad whoa
look at Joe santigato here dude you look
at my head look at that you look like as
Venetia would say a fuckboy
yeah yeah you have 100 FB status there
yeah you it is crazy it is it is it's
got to be very frustrating for women
that it is so true that men just look so
much better as they get older and women
start to look worse it's got to be
Beyond frustrating I I feel like there's
a point I think that is true but I think
there's a point where they're kind of
aligned like what years do you think
that is like in the 30s like the like
the like 28 to 33 I think is a
pocket of time where everyone kind of is
looks just as good as they're going to
look but also I don't even know if I
believe this dude some dudes I see from
like high school after a while and I'm
like dude you look [ __ ] like bad 47.
right like what happened no listen I'm
not saying first of all I don't
generalize anything but I'm just saying
most people you've heard that before
where they say guys start to look better
and then women start to look worse as
they get older now obviously it's not
true for everything but I mean you do
see it a lot I think that guys just get
away with more right the the dad bod
thing was like oh and it's like oh okay
you let it go it's getting but a woman a
woman can't you can't have Mom bod Dad
bod's okay but not mombot there's a
couple times where I've had mombod as a
man yeah and but am I right
all bodies are beautiful all body vanity
is off camera saying all bodies are
beautiful that's a lie and it's just we
gotta stop lying what do you mean it is
it is it is it wouldn't be Milford no
I'm kidding it is of course would a MILF
be well I think no no I'm saying dad bod
like for example I would say
dad bod are still in shape though when
you say kind of when when people are
like oh Dad bods are in and then you see
a dad bod and they're like oh this and
it's like this dude's like not
completely out of shape and he's just
like walking around but wouldn't that be
curvy for a woman curvy listen no no I
think curvy is bigger than a dad bod
like okay okay
I guess a mom bod would be maybe like a
fupa no I meant I meant the opposite
actually I meant a dad bod is way like
more body fat percentage than curvy
would be like I think about the spectrum
is like insane I just think two women
don't care as much about a guy's body as
a guy cares about a woman's body you
know what I mean I don't care either way
like yeah literally I genuinely don't
care as a matter of fact I just feel
like I've been asexual I have no I have
I'm talk Joe listen to me Christmas cats
Santa gato got it I have almost no sex
drive lately no jerking off no trying to
have sex I don't know what is going on
like it actually is bothering me where
I'm like because I still wake up with a
little morning wood
but I but I do feel like I press it down
do you ever go to that where you feel
like you have no sex drive at all
I mean when I'm like
depressed or something do you think I'm
just actually clinically depressed no I
think that you're just still figuring
out your sexuality and we're all
watching it in real time too
you don't know what's making you happy
you're like some days it's this some
days it's that the day I do figure it
out
oh but but I but it is strange where
it's like but it's uncomfortable with it
I'm at an age now where I'm comfortable
I'm not saying Jasmine is but I'm
comfortable not having sex like I
actually don't want to it's actually
like too much of a chore I'd rather just
relax with you watch Yellowstone yeah
cuddle a little bit maybe order the new
Pizza Hut sandwiches that they have and
just chill I don't wanna I don't I don't
need to have they're called melts Pizza
Hut melts they look good look at the
commercials how many calories pizza
melts oh God it's not a question you're
supposed to ask as long as I you never
ask a woman that as long as I have it in
my eating window
um I I but it's weird I don't you're
over it and I don't and and you know and
I'm sure that it's gonna you know I'm
sure eventually you know you can't get
away with this forever eventually you
know my girl's gonna be like we need to
have sex or I'm gonna look for it
elsewhere and I'm gonna say let's go
pick the guy together how long but I I
because I just don't want to do it I
don't want to deal with it I don't want
to have sex with anyone for any reason
I'm not even touching my own peepee even
when I go away to on hotels rooms for uh
gigs I don't even it's it's like just
when it's just gone do you feel smarter
do I feel smarter yeah because that was
a thing remember nofap it was like if
you don't jerk off for 30 days then like
you're gonna like and take cold shower
George Costanza remember he got smart
all of a sudden for not jerking off oh
that's right yeah that's right no I
don't feel smarter but I do feel more in
control I feel the most control in my
life now and maybe that's what it is
maybe I'm telling myself because I could
still get horny but even when I get
horny I'm like this is dumb so when you
come you lose control yeah I just I but
I don't even when I finally do come it's
gonna be wild dude when was the last
time you came
honestly three weeks ago maybe stop I
swear to god dude Christ I just I don't
know I don't know what it is I don't
know what the [ __ ] is going on there'll
definitely be blood when I finally do it
right but like there's there's been
times where I'm like oh I haven't
came and
six days I should do this medically
medically you should do it but do you
have a girlfriend or you sing you winky
yeah
[Music]
no yeah I do oh you have a girl for how
long a while oh wow so you've been so
you've been in the same now how often
with your girl do you got do you guys
still to this day if you've been
together longer than five years have sex
three to four times a week three or four
times it's not all the time but there's
weeks where it happens three to four
times
yeah right but there's also weeks where
it doesn't happen once yeah do you think
it's because I have kids do I have too
many kids I think that how many kids do
you have three
that's a lot of kids right and how old
are they 12 year old stepson uh a
seven-year-old biological daughter
one-year-old biological daughter but we
did never test we did never confirm that
it's that she's mine but her toes are
crossed over yeah our toes are crossed
over and she loves uh bacon so and
Nutella so she's probably my kid that's
pretty telling but so do you think
that's it
um maybe but I don't know it doesn't
sound like it's like a an issue of we
can't just find the time and we're
exhausted you're you're on the road by
yourself and you're like I'm not sure
you're just gonna go to sleep you know
what it could be I started taking new
blood pressure medicine you think that's
it probably three months ago I started
shout out losartan good blood pressure
meds
shout out losartan if you want to
sponsor the show shout him out by doing
my BP the other day was like 125 over
70. it's [ __ ] money wow I get the
best blood pressure in this room
probably but it's but I'm on but I'm on
juice you're cheating now what do you
guys think of all the rappers uh who now
believe that they're saving their come
because it drains their creative life
force the rappers are saying that they
save their come because it drains their
creative life force
I mean I would say that I'd say that
life force is pretty drained I was going
to say yeah as a rapper you have a short
life force anyway you're not going to
make it long rappers are starting to get
killed again which make I like that
Nostalgia it's making me it makes me
feel good that rapper's starting to get
killed again I'm waiting for the first
comic man after Chris Rock first comic
to get there will be a shooting in a
comedy club I have I don't know
I forget who would happen to but I'm
talking about a mass shooting um yeah if
you guys want to do a chrisd.com got new
dates West Palm Beach we've just added
this one guns are legal just wants to be
the first legal guns Phoenix January
26th to the 28th that's great and guess
what Vancouver Canada might be hard we
added that one and we ordered Austin I'm
opening up moon tower uh Comedy Festival
in Austin at the Paramount so bring your
guns christycomedy.com for Ticky wikis I
said no one's getting shot in Vancouver
I think if you really want to prove how
good you are do the shoot come to get
the gun into my show in Vancouver
there's like eight people a year die
from guns in Canada or something no
crazy dude yeah I think it's like four
nobody does more people do blackface
um
all right
all right baby door Dash you know we
love doordash here we like to unlock
savings from the local restaurants we I
use doordash every day of my life got
the dash dash pass uh membership which
is dope everything's about memberships
now get the dash pass okay because
literally you enjoy its zero delivery
fees on every eligible order that's
right zero they'll uh you get the lower
service fees on all eligible orders and
five percent to our Dash credits back on
pickup orders doordash literally I mean
you know everything's on the phone right
now everything's an app just download
that doordash app put it in and you're
gonna get for a limited time the
listeners to the hey bay podcast which
we thank you guys so much for you're
gonna enjoy a gift of 50 off up to a
twenty dollar value and zero dollar
delivery fees when you download the
doordash app and enter code hey babe22
that's hey babe22 50 off up to a twenty
dollar value zero delivery fees download
the doordash app in the app store enter
the code hey babe22 do not forget code
hey babe 22 50 off up to a 20 value
and zero delivery fees promo code hey
babe 22 subject to change terms apply
love you doordash
door babe
this Show sponsored by betterhelp love
it this episode brought to you by
betterhelp betterhelp it's helped me
it's helped sell it's helped everyone in
this room but homeless pimp because he's
not using it and he needs to get on it
he needs to get on it why should I try
it you should try pimp you should try
better help because you just you seem
stressed and you're just under a lot of
pressure rightfully so we work you in
here we work you in here like you know
we work you to death so what would I do
on better hope so what you do on better
help is first of all you can literally
if you want to you can get on a zoom
with a trusted guidance counselor from
betterhelp and you can literally do a
session naked if you want you can be
butt naked you don't have to waste time
going to an actual office instead you
can save time and you can go to better
help on zoom and then edit more clips
that we [ __ ] tell you to edit okay
cool great you can do it and you can do
that while you listen to all Opie and
Anthony episodes yeah yeah yeah well
while you're drooling
so better help what also is great about
Better Health pimp is it's connected
over three million people with licensed
therapists it's convenient and it's
accessible anywhere and it is 100
online and that's where you live most of
your life pip is online you're an online
Guy this is an online service okay you
can talk to you don't have to it's you
don't have to take Edibles every night
you can instead of why don't you take
why not instead of taking an edible why
don't you take an edible emotionally by
talking to a counselor on Better Health
oh my God sounds amazing it's the
world's largest therapy service it's
matched three million people
professionally licensed and vetted
therapists and literally because you're
a fan of the show right now all you got
to do is go to betterhelp that's help
betterhelp.com hey babe and you're gonna
get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com hey babe 10 off your
first month pimp are you gonna do it
right after I edit the Chrissy chaos
patreon episode that's right because
that's coming up next
how about this people in power Vladimir
zielinski the president of Ukraine who
should have been dead months ago is now
the Time magazine's person of the year
do you remember last February when this
started the news was like zelenski's
gonna die any minute I was pretty and
I'm a Gambling Man I haven't hit a
parlay in weeks so I'm not the best one
DraftKings who's the sponsor uh
[Laughter]
actually no I wanted to give this to you
I forgot this is in my pocket hell yeah
dude it's the hot sauce whoa yeah look
at this everything bagel hot sauce by
the heatonist is this is this from your
show we may that's my hot sauce hot
sauce you're making well [ __ ] taste
buds eat your heart out they got to the
hot sauce game first sorry DeRosa I mean
his hot sauce and I'm gonna eat the hot
sauce right in front of you when I can
see you next time you pig
they hated me before he's Gonna Hate Me
Now oh yeah oh it's good Bottle too good
packages
you suck oh god um I'd love to film an
episode of their show at derose's
restaurant oh no please do it they
should film an episode here
uh we should do it we should do a show
with them yeah no that's how you go
that's how good Joe is good business why
don't we bring it all together do it all
together and then show a live audience
how much better they're
and then
um did you guys see that they're
starting a 147 000 a year salary job to
kill the rats in New York 147 Grand a
year just to kill the rats what does
that even [ __ ] mean dude just release
a bunch of cats that's all you got to do
dude I would just release everybody's
house I would make it illegal to have a
house cat if you have a house cat it has
to be outside and then that thing will
start killing all the rats dude nobody
kills more rats than cats dude but the
cats are all meet up and then start
attacking people oh 170 000 actually
more oh wow nice look at that that's
ridiculous but what does that even mean
that you have to like go out and with
like I guess set traps go like on rat
hunts but but the thing is I think that
the way that rats procreate they evolve
they create so much quicker like you
kill one there's ten more they should
just put out like a [ __ ] statement of
like yo just kill every right you see
like with those bugs that was it what
were they called uh what were they the
stupid
and I was killing I was killing those by
the [ __ ] dude my daughter was like an
assassin with those she would come and
just people get excited 30 at a time
throw them in the pool dude did you see
a a person of color was killing them in
the street and then somebody called the
cops really
killing all the Flies yeah I love it uh
some guy I was at a I was at a uh like a
launch at like a nice place and I got
and One landed on the floor this guy got
up out of his seat and jumped on it like
it was a live grenade yeah like
literally like jumped on it was like
stop it that's the live that's the most
American thing you can do is my
government told me to kill Lantern bucks
because they they came here from China
and that's the enemy yeah so that's what
it is the land it's not China's the
enemy the Chinese lantern bugs exactly
that's who we're at war with yeah I
think you could play Vladimir zielinski
in the movie I could see you me playing
zelenski I think so now I'm not only
Puerto Rican but I'm Ukrainian you're in
Ukrainian Port dude you're racially
ambiguous that's the bet dude the best
thing that ever happened to you is you
were born racially and big I don't I
think you're the only person thinking
that I can't do
odling you I'm not go tweet at hey bay
pod write on the YouTube comments did
you think Joe santigato was a Dominican
relief pitcher for the Mets yes or no
so I mean the fact that he won person of
the year Time Magazine I understand why
I get it but it just feels like if the
media was saying this guy was gonna die
a year ago that they were like closing
on his location and now he's alive it
just makes me and now he's person here
it just makes me feel like the media is
controlling this all like they're
protecting him they're setting all this
up like I just feel like I don't know if
Russia is as bad as they say but why
would they do that like what what does
it mean like obviously he's gonna be
protected he's the [ __ ] president
yeah but he was post the media was
outwardly saying last February he's
going to die any day passed on he was
out in the streets I'm like this guy
might want a duck because I don't know
about this it is funny though how like
just to count not even a calendar like
less than a year later Vlad like you
would think it's it's the mighty Putin
for salensky who's hiding in a hole now
zelenski is on the cover of Time
Magazine and Putin's falling down the
stairs [ __ ] his pants was that like
confirmed right fell down the stairs and
[ __ ] his pants that's fine it's like
such a flip it's like if you told me if
like if you told me like Switcheroo
history is like this like if you told me
30 years ago hey here's Bill Cosby
here's Mr Rogers which one's going to be
in prison I'd be like Mr Rogers dude
this guy [ __ ] puts his shoes on on
live television he's a creep Cosby's the
man but then it's a flipper real Cosby's
a creep although Mr Rogers I just think
it's no he was a nice guy I think
there's I'm gonna find what's wrong with
you Rogers I'm coming he probably was
really into some weird sexual stuff but
like oh he was gay right Mr Rogers is
gay I think can we all agree with that
wife
I mean dude who's washing their feet in
a kiddie pool that doesn't have some
crimes they've covered up seriously
that's it that you don't think that Mr
Rogers is has did something criminal
some criminal activity I think that
we're just jaded you know anyone who's
nice you're like okay you can't be too
nice also have you did you watch the
documentary you don't think that it's a
quinky dinky that Tom Hanks the Greek
pedophile played him in the movie
alleged pad
yeah he's on a bunch of flyless isn't he
on the logs Mr Rogers you know it's
going to be classic you know it's going
to be classic when Elliot page plays Mr
Rogers
yeah I cried in his documentary you
cried at Mr Rogers documentary almost
are you on steroids no no no no no
why I never saw that Mr Rogers
documentary we like to do movie wrecks
here on hey babe it was it was good I
liked it because you're like because I
was the same way or I mean this guy is
like super nice and like anyone who does
like a kid show I'm always just like
what's going on you know like yeah but
dude like pull up this clip Google
no that's not it
um all right forget it wow look at Lou
Ferrigno dude [ __ ] God just a massive
[ __ ] dude look at that
would you really want to be that Jack
though absolutely nice I don't get that
kind of do really I always think about
how they how do they wipe some of them
are so huge I'm like there has to be an
assistant yeah yeah someone's swiping
their [ __ ] right also I'm just thinking
about dude the second you stop working
out now you're just a huge dude it's no
different than being 800 pound life or
whatever it is it's the same point
that's the same point you're just a fat
[ __ ] all right we could skip it you know
why we should skip it anyway because I
we should probably edit this point out
because it's a clip on my vice show
um
oh you're doing bits from Vice now yeah
I should probably not I should probably
not do the bits from the TV show that's
coming out on the pod
just cut edit all that part out and I'm
back Vladimir Putin fell down the stairs
should himself what do you guys think of
all the crypto billionaires mysteriously
dying every crypto Bill did you get ever
get in crypto did you ever get hot and
heavy with it yeah but not not enough to
like hurt it doesn't bother you like I
was just playing a game kind of do you
have it still like just you just yeah
I'm just gonna leave it there yeah until
it comes back I'm not I'm not really
like you know I didn't put enough in
that I would be like oh my god well now
they're they're apparently being hunted
on that Puerto Rican Island remember you
had said you knew a bunch of people
moved there for tax oh it Oh you mean in
Puerto Rico yeah just because if you
live in Puerto Rico you only pay four
percent tax rate so a lot of
millionaires crypto Millionaires and
billionaires were moving to Puerto Rico
instead of getting taxed 40 they got
taxed four wow by your people that you
say you're not a party alleged allegedly
yeah I know if you walked into Puerto
Rico they'd be like well come on papa no
it was okay
um
uh dude you ever go to Puerto Rico I
haven't I want to go really bad I went
for the first time uh last year dude
unbelievable best mangoes you'll ever
have in your life I believe that I've
definitely had mangoes from like a
Puerto Rico but you've never had a mango
from the island dude it tastes like
you're biting into JLo's ass oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
dude so how where's uh where's Frankie
where's your boy Frankie what's he doing
today you know he's in Jersey living it
up he has a baby on the way you know on
the way yeah is this his first kid uh
second dude let me tell you something I
was telling them before when you have
one child it's great it's difficult
being a parent's very hard when you have
two kids you might as well have 40. yeah
the fact having two children like I you
know I've three you know but my stepson
he's 12 and he hates me so it's whatever
yeah so so I yeah and no he does
actually you're right he doesn't hate me
he doesn't but he was throwing up last
week and he was throwing up on the
carpet and he couldn't move and I picked
him up and threw him in the [ __ ]
shower why could he not move because he
was throwing up super mobile and I was
like I was just
I am I am I am I I can't I like I move
around a lot like I'll even dance around
the toilet bowl for some reason I'm like
moving when you need to puke yeah when
I'm when I'm puking dude I'm all over
the [ __ ] house you know I had n't
puked like not even uh not even a
stomach bug I hadn't puked in five years
I've puked twice in the past month
[ __ ] two multiple pukes isn't it
weird yeah I think it is weird what do
you do with the one well you're not
jerking off so maybe that was that has
something to do with it I feel bad I
think I might have said this on the
podcast I feel I I felt feel terrible
shout out to Liberty Hotel in Boston
great Hotel I threw up all over it all
over in the sink and I cleaned all the
chunks up with chunks is disgusting work
yeah I cleaned all the I cleaned all the
chunks up with with bath towels and I
left the puke-filled bath towels on the
floor and I put them in a neat pile but
I didn't have any cashed tip so I left
no tip my God I left a stomach virus and
[ __ ] puke chunks and I left no tip
and I feel horrible but what I'll say is
all hotels should have some type of QR
code where I can instantly uh send money
into a pot for the uh uh maids and Guy
Maids I don't think they're counting on
people having a stomach [ __ ] in their
[ __ ] nope but how many times do we
not have cash and now I gotta go down to
the ATM pay a 3.50 fee just to come back
up and leave twenty dollars for the
house cleaning crew if there was a QR
code where I could just scan it it's on
my desk you know it's on my nightstand I
can then send them the money and this
way you know no I agree and also like uh
like parking garages and valets like
yeah they won't let you tip with your
card when you pay with your card and
they're like oh no I was just like well
I just don't have cash on it or if I
have a 20 Bill like we're gonna be we're
gonna break the 20 like what do you want
me to do yesterday was the first day I I
I I I I got a car service and then I
didn't have cash to tip and I asked the
guy for his venmo and he just he was
very he had opened up scanned his Venom
I venmo him his tip and it worked out
but then these people that don't have
venmo it's like you know then you're not
gonna get tipped what do you want me to
do give you my French fries
yeah I'll give you my Pizza Hut Panini
it's a difficult War though we live in
me and you honestly you live in a
different let's talk about how the
struggles of being a straight white male
I know it's different allegedly yeah
alleged a legend I'm posing
it is no I know I
though I will say this I think the world
today is not any more difficult or crazy
than it was 50 years ago it's just we
see it all now so you have this illusion
that things are more different I believe
it's not it's it's actually was so much
worse 50 years ago it's just you didn't
see it like if I told you like you could
be in a room right here right and one of
us could have a a a you could I could
have the stomach virus I'm gonna give to
you but you have no idea you don't have
any clue you're living you have no idea
it's even happening but then if I told
you hey by the way I think I have a
stomach bug now all of a sudden it's on
your mind you're worried could I have it
could I not ignorance is bliss and I
think back in the day it was good to be
ignorant now with cameras on the whole
world it's a little bit like people
think it's worse than it actually is
yeah not work the world is not you do
not want to be you would not have liked
the world 50 years ago I promise you two
things I want to say one say two and
only two if you say three I'm gonna ask
you to leave
the first one legitimately every single
time that I do a podcast with you you
have some sort of illness and in between
that one of the times I went to your
show at the comedy seller and I was
talking to you backstage and you're like
oh and after like 10 minutes of talk he
goes by the way I have like 102 fever
and I'm like
thanks dude every single time because I
came to your house you're like I got
black mold in the walls I'm like dude
I'm here already first of all it's
African-American malt I
I I don't
um I get Sicky Wiki a little bit more
because I got little kids my little ones
in daycare yeah yeah and then you know
they're all they're all booger infested
kids but I do think you know I won't be
as sick you know when I'm like four when
my kids a little older I won't be as
sick but yes but I do get I do get sick
uh you know a little too much yeah and
the second thing I wanted to say was
that I definitely like go out of my way
to try and not be as informed as I am
sometimes because I'm like I wish I just
didn't [ __ ] know this yeah like every
single time someone dies I gotta hear
about it and I'm like [ __ ] that's sad
and I'm pretty sensitive too if you are
sensitive to like information you know
what I mean so if I learn something and
I'm like oh dude I didn't I didn't or
like my sister will send me a [ __ ]
like a tick tock of some [ __ ] dog
that ran away and I'm like what the [ __ ]
are you sending me this for it's like
ruining my day it's 8 A.M what the [ __ ]
are you doing I know it's like dude it's
like not not everything needs to be a
sob story that's not that's why I'm not
watching the lizzo documentary on HBO
Max it's like
it's like we get it okay you're [ __ ]
you're a multi-millionaire shut up if
you make over a million dollars a year
you should you should just shut your
mouth
you should you should just shut up you
literally if you're making over a
million dollars a year and you're in the
public eye you should literally only be
allowed to come on television and talk
about how much your life how [ __ ]
amazing your life is and how the little
peasants just you should you should
really strive to be a multi-millionaire
and I don't want to hear one complaint
coming out of your [ __ ] fat mouth if
you're making over a million dollars a
year no matter what race religion Creed
I don't give a [ __ ] about your struggle
you won if you got the money you won
then and your struggle is now irrelevant
it's that was yesterday babe shut up and
keep making the money if you make 999
000 a year I'll hear from you you poor
piece of [ __ ] tell us again about how
you don't come anymore
literally I would have that rant I just
went on is the first time I got blood
flow to my dick
I watch another HBO Max what'd you watch
uh there's a shortage of uh black Santas
there's a shortage of black Santas yeah
really what's the quota I don't know but
these other Santas were crying on camera
about it it was very bizarre white
Santas were crying about yeah okay yeah
some people I mean this is the you know
I have no idea but like people are very
I guess they have pride about being
Santa Claus to the point where they're
like represented as a I think Santa
doesn't Santa shouldn't be attached to a
race or even if sexuality I think San is
I think Santa's are sexually ambiguous
and racially ambiguous
well he has a wife he does okay but he
well why don't we say that Mrs Claus now
is a partner why don't we say it's a
partner instead of a wife we could yeah
Santa's partner
we could technically say that I mean you
never really even hear about Mrs Claus
anymore that was I was a thing in the
90s you don't even Santa Claus is just
like a lone wolf even get got out of Mrs
Claus yeah probably I think they like
pushed her out they're like women are
getting too much now yeah we don't need
this no we don't need it yeah I mean
well really like Santa Claus is Jeff
Bezos Amazon we've talked about this
Amazon is Santa Claus that that's yeah
you're set listen here's the truth Santa
Claus kids if you're listening at home
and we know that you are Santa Claus is
a small Jewish man on steroids yeah and
his name's Jeff Bezos I wasn't gonna fit
that in by the way I was gonna be like
on hch by the way because he is out of
nowhere yoked Jeff Bezos that really
[ __ ] pissed me off I'm like you can't
be the richest man in the world where I
was second or whatever the [ __ ] and
then get jacked no it's not [ __ ] you
dude speaking of that did you see Joe
Rogan call out the rock yesterday for
what Joe Rogan called out the rock
yesterday or two days ago and said that
he was like I wanna The Rock needs to
come clean and say that he's on steroids
and there's no way his body can look
like that he was like because Joe was
like if you're gonna do it then be open
Joe was like I'm very open about being
on HGH The Rock shouldn't lie to the
kids that look up to him and be like you
can look like this naturally over 50.
it's impossible so does he the Rocks
probably does is probably like Joe shut
up was this based on liver King is this
what it exactly based off bro if you
thought that that guy was not on
steroids you should be tar and feathered
in front of a live audience yeah because
look at them like obviously this dude
isn't [ __ ] natural yeah he's a freak
look at him yeah it's literally like if
you literally like just eat testicles
and you'll have you'll be look like this
like it's like Oh The Rock's not on
steroids oh I guess Ryan Seacrest isn't
gay either yeah come on guys Gabriel
you're [ __ ] we know Seacrest is gay
we know rocks on steroids what is he
Crest up to see Chris what is he up to
now I haven't seen him in a while he's
on uh he's on a pride picks
the uh producer of the Kardashian show
even though they moved from E he's still
like um what does that have to do if
he's gay or not snakes the money is he
gay he actually produces the Kardashians
dude the money Ryan Seacrest has his
next 11. honestly deserves it guy's a
good host love Ryan team and listen what
happened he never [ __ ] and complains
about his problems zoomed in the fact
that he's five eight which means that
he's five six five six he's from
Dunwoody Georgia what is what a fun town
hey I'm from Dunwoody imagine the other
37. whoa remember he had a co-host and
they dropped him Ryan Seacrest had a
co-host on American Idol when they first
launched
there was another guy in there oh okay
yeah wow pimpy knows it pimpy I like to
pimp pimp watch his shows like a [ __ ]
housewife yeah why not
wait my alarm went off oh uh birth
control just in Vancouver and West Palm
I already did bring your guns yeah
um your guns
so um Kelly Ripa by the way hello
oh my god oh he's Live with Kelly that's
a good looking
couple right there Kelly ripo's in shape
Kelly Ripa is beat the [ __ ] out of me
dude Kelly Ripa Kelly Ripa is ripped
remember her husband Mark Consuelos was
ripped that dude is hot as [ __ ] what if
Mark can sweat the last thing could
swallow sounds like you made up a Latino
name yeah that sounds like you like
trying to be like half racist or
something like you think my last name
was yeah my guys Joe could swell yeah
exactly
I uh what are you doing for the rest of
the day Joe oh my God look at this guy I
want to know about your day what'd you
have for breakfast dude I didn't serious
eat breakfast you haven't eaten oh are
you intermittent fasting let's talk
about it no I just get lazy sometimes
whoa so when's the last time you ate
when did you what did you eat last night
I haven't eaten in three weeks uh yeah
last night what did I have chickpea
pasta oh did you cook do you cook the
guys want to know I cook but not as
often as I should right but you could
cook like if I said Joe you need to cook
for the week you could make a meal you
could make three meals a day every day
variety you know how to cook stuff if I
was a chicken parm do it you can do it
yeah yeah I can make chicken parm it's
just easy what is it you chicken what do
you get chicken [ __ ] bread crumbs
eggs some eggs you know what I mean dip
it in you need [ __ ] fresh mats and
you put it in the [ __ ] oven that's it
put it up now homemade sauce that you
get in canned all right [ __ ] it yeah
well yeah
yeah you won't you don't make a homemade
sauce no I'm not no you know what and I
don't have any grandparents so no one's
making it in their garage or anything
like that you know what bothers me but I
just have to deal with it yeah my
girlfriends her ex-boyfriend taught her
how to make sauce and the sauce is
banging yeah but every time I eat it I'm
like I feel like I'm eating has come
yeah well
I feel like you that was a big reach
yeah like it could have been that's
crazy yeah yeah I do I think that's
crazy I knew a guy who moved into a
building he moved into an apartment
building like a real nice luxury Condo
building yeah with his girlfriend
was in day one in the elevator with his
girlfriend like literally getting the
[ __ ] from the U-Haul truck and the
girlfriend saw an ex-boyfriend she had
in high school that lived in the
building what a clinky dink that kid
that guy moved out him and his
girlfriend he they moved out of the
building the next day broke the lease
and he left you know this person I know
this person personally I was like what a
dummy well the most insecure person of
all time obviously could you imagine
doing that yeah no I mean I would who
cares right no why the [ __ ] would you
give a [ __ ] I don't and also a lease to
break the lease is like thousands of
dollars yeah I can't deal with this I
used to this
this is how insecure I used to be every
girlfriend I had like when I was like
Eve like in my late 20s my first
question would be like how many guys
have you had sex with like and then it
would I would force them you know like
pressure them to like give me an answer
which was so dumb yeah and then you know
they never cared about because girls are
more mature they never cared about my
answer and then like whatever their
answer was it would bother me and now
it's like what a dumb people do that
like why do you care about somebody's
past especially like the younger
generation right now like that's
literally all of the content on like
Tick Tock and [ __ ] it's like them asking
women or just like talking about women
and how many sexual partners they have
and like what's acceptable and what
isn't acceptable and the real answer to
these guys is legit zero or one yeah
it's like if you want to really
experience girl she has one sexual
partner if she has two what I legit saw
a video the other day of of a woman
actually uh talking to a girl who said
she had two sexual partners and she was
18 years old okay and and they were
making it seem like this girl had [ __ ]
thousands right had sex with two people
at 18. 18. all right hope you enjoyed
that episode with the very very funny
and hot Joe santigato Sal vulcano will
be back next week don't worry about it
and babe we have about 45 minutes of
that episode that we just could not put
out there for the masses we could not
put it on YouTube so it's all at
patreon.com christycomedy where me and
Joey went wild so that's at patreon.com
christycomedy Joe santigato and I
talking ish was just not fit for uh hey
babe but babe don't I thought that
episode was great which always Santa
gato I thought it was great and the rest
is at patreon.com Christy comedy so
enjoy them both
foreign
[Music]